hot breath oh louie louie was amazing
uh louie [ __ ] jesus he's you know
he's
he's the guy i watched before i even did
comedy so to work with him
it's like that seinfeld thing he's like
i can't believe life is so long
that i'm working with people i grew up
watching
you know and uh just probably the best
comic working today he's like our carlin
and uh just edgy and poignant
interesting and
original so original uh he's a guy who
worries about if this joke has been done
to the to a t and he's like i've heard
jokes like that so i won't go that way
he's just
he's the king and uh just a humble guy
like if you compliment him he gets all
embarrassed and he just cares about good
comedy
and uh just sweet guy and very giving
and
those shows were amazing and watching
him was amazing so yeah
so you guys special you guys sat down
and like discussed jokes
like oh yeah we would bounce bits
because jokes are his whole life that's
all that's his whole thing
so he would he'd like what are you
working on what do you got it's [ __ ]
terrifying you go i got this idea and
he's like oh that's good but i remember
we had a great note
i had one joke i would talk about how
getting dizzy
is a kid's version of getting drunk like
getting dizzy is that's what kids
you know whine what do you call it uh
take the take the edge off
you know like i had a rough day i'm
gonna hit that merry-go-round blah blah
blah silly joke very
you know cutesy but he uh he was like we
gotta make it personal so now
he's like every joke is funnier if it's
personal so i never forgot that i'm like
all right i gotta remember that every
time i'm writing i go like make it
personal make it personal
so instead of saying hangovers are weird
i go i was hungover today
you know just make it it goes it gives
it an extra little kick